l'abbaye de la carte est dieu fondée en
12 139 classé aux monuments historiques
en 2011
elle a été retenue par la fondation dern
le loto du patrimoine mais depuis pas de
nouvelles il y a urgence pour temps de
restaurer entre autres cette superbe
charpente de 30 mètres de long d'un
ancien dortoir de moines cisterciens
nous avons envoyé donc par internet on a
déclaré et nous n'avons pas eu une ni
deux accusés de réception ni aucune
confirmation
et ça a mis plusieurs mois et c'est que
plein de temps que l'on nous a appelé en
disant vous avez été élu ils n'ont pas
attendu pour débuter des travaux à
hauteur de 57 milles euros soutenu par
une association d'amis de la bi il
faudrait trois cent mille euros
on ne pouvait pas attendre le résultat
du loto pour sauver la charpente qui
était en train de se pencher de
s'affaisser des pièces tombé s'est pas
encore tous payés mais et voilà on ne
sait pas du tout où on va puisque on n'a
pas encore de nouvelles de du résultat
et le site gigantesque de la clarté dieu
n'a pas dévoilé tous ses secrets et sa
richesse patrimoniale
en dessous il ya une salle qui est à 260
probablement sous voûte d'ogives qui est
absolument splendide que nous avons pu
étayer va vous de s'affaisser
complètement ça c'était aussi à à
quelques semaines près c'était était
partie le montant de la dotation l'auto
patrimoine reste donc un mystère
et pourtant le temps presse en france
250 sites sont toujours en attente de
réponse seuls 18 projets ont déjà été
financés